I decided to join Teen Mom because of a
lot of reasons I read this book recently
and it was all about turning your wounds
into someone else's wisdom and your hurt
into someone else's healing and your
breakdown into someone else's
breakthrough and it really changed my
perspective on a lot of things and made
me realize that God gave me a platform
and that was to serve others and if I
can do that with this show of you know
letting people know they're not alone
after and they're the same struggles you
know across the nation so that's why I
decided to do it was to hopefully
encourage others and to let them know
that life isn't over after a divorce for
sure Bristol Palin isn't afraid to share
her truth on the upcoming season
premiere of Teen Mom og not only will
the series explore her journey becoming
a mom at 18 we'll also see her
relationship with her now ex-husband
Dakota Meyer my husband Dakota has been
struggling with PTSD and it's been hard
on our marriage I don't want to raise my
kids to think that it says what a
marriage looks like Dakota's PTSD has
always been a known factor it's it's
always there I mean his service for our
country is like unbelievable I can't
imagine the stuff that he's that he's
seen and I'm appreciative of him doing
the show I don't care what he says about
me I think it's it's great that he's
doing the show because it is gonna shed
light on PTSD and it's gonna shed light
on an issue that's not talked about
enough I think that our marriage was
something that was very fast and he
would agree too and there's a lot of
things that we probably both wish we
would have done differently I think
there's a lot of things that we would
advise our children to do different
absolutely I knew that I was gonna be
facing a difficult time because our
marriage was so rocky a relationship was
so on and off the timing of it all was
in my opinion you know God's plan for me
to sit here and talk about real issues
so everything that's gone on I do
I feel God's presence in it and I just
hope that we can both you know in in our
different paths encourage people and
help people and hopefully let others
know that they're not
not alone I go to sleep at night knowing
that I did give it my all today at 27
Bristol is putting her best foot forward
I'm thankful for the road that's got me
here and I'm thankful for you know the
mom that I'm becoming in the woman that
I'm becoming
[Music]